it's developing into this global town
square that is fueled by free expression
where the public gathers in real time
hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you I think we should
start with sort of the most recent major
announcement which is the company now
being called X why did you do this
Rebrand
well first of all I think we need to
rewind a little bit and and remind
ourselves that Elon has been talking
about X the everything app for a very
long time even when we announced that I
was joining the company I was joining
the company to partner with Elon to
transform Twitter into X the everything
app
so you know I also at the heart of the
Rebrand
X we need to keep our minds open that
it's developing into this global town
square that is fueled by free expression
where the public gathers in real time
and I want to stop on that for a second
because in real time is what's most
important about the vibrancy of X and
how people interact with it and now it's
all in one seamless interface so think
about what's happened since the
acquisition right experiences and
evolution into long-form video and
articles subscribe to your favorite
creators who are now earning a real
living on the platform which is so
exciting
you look at video and you look at soon
you'll be able to make video chat calls
without having to give your phone number
to anyone on the platform
and then payments
payments there's been a lot of talk
about that payments between you and a
friend between you and one of your
creators yeah so there's been a lot
going on in the Rebrand represented
really a liberation
from Twitter a Liberation that allowed
us to evolve past a legacy mindset and a
thinking and to reimagine how everyone
everyone on Spaces who's listening
everybody who's watching around the
world it's going to change how we
congregate how we entertain how we
transact all in one place